34 times 70 you may not have seen
multiplications set out like this before
you know you might just see all on one
line like this but the whole idea is to
make it a bit more logical and
systematic and make sure I don't miss
any part of the question okay so the
reason they've sent out like this is to
show I've got three different parts of
34 then I want to multiply it one at a
time so I'll do 7 times 4 then I moved
seven times 30 okay so seven times four
seven times four my seven times tables 7
14 21 28 is the fourth one right so 28
is 7 times 4 that's what I put
underneath
I've done the 7 by 4 now do the 7 times
30
cuz it's 7 times 13 I'm not seven times
3 which is just what looks like it's
there now 3 actually has a zero and
hanging on with it right so a zero comes
up straight away and now I can do 7
times 3 and I just did the 7 so 7 14 21
to 1 so I've done the two parts now I'm
gonna okay now just before I answer any
questions this is the exact value that
I'm looking for so okay done and it
wasn't too difficult but here's where
this comes in and is really useful right
34 times 7 is one of those they kind of
messy numbers right so what I'm going to
do is just to check that I know I'm in
the right ballpark and haven't done
something crazy and wrong I'm going to
round both of these numbers and see what
happens
right so when I round these 34 I'll
round that to the nearest 10 what's the
nearest 10 to 34 very good vegan so 30
is the closest one and then when I look
at 7 I can round that to the nearest
tenth I don't have to do it but I might
as well the nearest tenth of this is
what's just 10
right so 30 times 10 that's super easy
that's 300 now 300 as it happens because
of my granny cube it is a little bit off
by at least I know like I don't have the
wrong number 0 something like that I'm
not half or double what I'm supposed to
be so I know I'm sort of in the right
ballpark okay and for each of the
questions you do when this one is really
hard and you're taking a long time to go
through that food not sure how accurate
I then what I'd like you to do is try
grounding right round each of the
numbers to an appropriate accuracy and
then give it a shot cuz they rounded
it's easy and then you know if you're
roughly round
any questions
you put you put the numbers on there
like this say you got eight and then she
is that right and the year seven times
three so you've got 21 plus two which is
it that's absolutely fine that's all
okay I think that's all what you can see
we ended up at the same answer one of
the reasons why I'm sending it out like
this is the when the numbers start to
get a bit big right you start to end up
getting a lot of numbers flying around
up here and it can be easy to confuse
them right so this is one of those
places where mathematicians like yeah we
have lots of different ways to do this
then kind of hands-on how difficult the
question is and how confident I am and
how quick I can do it so that's
absolutely fine if you do it that way
thumbs up